you know what occurred to me today  how early the signs were that i have  adhd  i should clarify um i know uh a lot of  folks  um on this app are like finding out as  adults that they have adhd i actually  i've known since i was in seventh grade  but i can tell you something that should  have been assigned way  back from grade school so first through  fifth grade  i used to walk home from school i didn't  have to  there was a bus but i chose to walk home  from school  because i wasn't as bored it was not any  faster  often times the bus would pass me with  about five minutes left to go my walk  but i would rather walk  almost a mile every day after school  than sit there and be bored waiting for  the bus  early signs